beantworte meine
Fragen wenn wir deine
Fragen ja ich habe nicht wirklich damit
gerechnet schinst also habe ich mir auch
noch keine richtigen Fragen überlegt
also irgendeine Frage an BU wird dir ja
woh einfallen oder also gut ich habe ein
paar Fragen aber eigentlich würde ich
die lieber Christop krachten von
klickoom stellen was ST BR stellst du
deine Fragen ber an einen
internetreporter also gut stell deine
Fragen und ich wer mit meinen
übernatürlichen wterkräften chr K
weiterleiten ja lieber Christop ich
würde gern von Dir wissen was du für ein
Ruf bei den Stars hast also haben die
teilweise Angst vor dir und möchten
keine Interviews weil du die Sachen doch
so ungeschnitten zeigst und auch Patz
mal drin lässt ja zweite Frage Christoph
was halten die Kollegen vom Fernsehen
von klickzom also gibt es da z.B viele
Neider oder harte Kritik beglückwünschen
sie dich zu deiner Idee das würde mich
mal interessieren also ja dein Ruf bei
den Stars und dein Ruf bei den TV
Kollegen danke schön
Budha jo erstmal vielen Dank für diese
sensationelle Frage Lenny und vielen
Dank auch an Budha für die Übermittlung
sie ist angekommen ja welches Image
genieße ich bei meinen Gästen ich glaube
bei meinen Gästen also die Leute die
wirklich zu mir kommen bei denen genieße
ich ein sehr gutes Image äh die freuen
sich dass da mal einer sitzt äh der ihn
wirklich zuhört und die Fragen auch aus
den Antworten formuliert und eben nicht
da so ein vorbereiteten Fragenkatalog
hat aber ich kann mir vorstellen es gibt
Leute bei denen ich nicht so ein guten
Ruf habe das S nämlich aber glau ich
diejenigen die nicht kommen da könnte
ich mir vorstellen dass der ein oder
andere so ein bisschen Manschetten hat
weil er wenn er eine Fassade zeigt die
vielleicht nicht aufrecht erhalten kann
und davor so ein bisschen Befürchtung
hat aber ich kann es nicht beurteilen
weil die diejenigen die kommen ja dann
nicht na ja und der Ruf bei meinen
Kollegen die stehen da meistens wirklich
bewundernd und staunend davor weil die
eigentlich das super spannend finden
dass da einer dass es da einen gibt den
Sie von früher kennen der mit ihnen
zusammengearbeitet hat und der jetzt auf
Youtube wie ja selbst eben das ztf nicht
in dem Maße oder die ARD oder wie sie
alle heißen selbst die kommen ja mit
Mühe auf solche Abrufzahlen wie wir sie
haben und das finden die schon extrem
spannend und die finden das Format auch
glaube ich wirklich sehr sehr gut das
macht ihn Spaß anzugucken aber die
wissen auch dass das so natürlich im
Fernsehen nicht laufen würde
und Rätseln dann so ein bisschen was sie
auf Youtube machen können also das spont
die immer so ein bisschen an ach ich
müsste auch was machen was kann ich noch
machen also das ist so die Meinung
meiner
Kollegen